yeah you know at this point I keep
coming back I'm doing it to myself
Batman versus Robin and I I really
didn't want to watch this at this point
I don't even know why I did the DC
animated movies lately have been
inconsistent at best and all the ones
based off of the new 52 continuity which
at this point includes Justice League
war throne of Atlantis son of Batman I
have really really not liked I keep
coming back hoping it's gonna somehow
turn around even though I have now
actually read some of the new 52
material that these are based off of and
not like that either so it's not even a
case of bad adaptation I don't like the
source material yet I keep coming back
and I need to stop normally at this
point I do a plot synopsis but really
kind of title says it all we're going
exactly where things left off in terms
of son of Batman and Damian who is the
current Robin and also Batman's
biological son and Batman are just
butting heads over and over until it
comes down to they actually come to
blows at one point there's a little bit
more going on it borrows a little bit
from the court of owls storyline from
the new 52 along with their assassins
and the character of Talon but it's very
straightforward this is not a
particularly nuanced story that's being
told now if I'm gonna give credit where
credit is due
I'm gonna single out Talon because one
of the things that all of these new 52
based animated movies have had is a
villain problem Darkseid wasn't a
character he was just a boss fight at
the end of Justice League war
Deathstroke and sunna Batman was
horrible that one I'm blaming on the
voice actor worm in throne of Atlantis
was an idiot talon is a good villain
doing no small part because they scrap
to the completely crap backstory that he
was given in the new 52 he's got a new
backstory which makes MUC much more
sense and makes him a much more
interesting parallel to Batman himself I
won't spoil what that is it's not played
as a twist or anything but it's later
revelation so I'll leave it at that
but also
putting it over the top is the voice
work of Jeremy Sisto who not only just
delivers a good performance in and of
itself but also lends a certain amount
of metatextual weight because Jeremy
Sisto himself has voiced Batman before
back in Justice League new frontier so
if you've been following these movies
for a long time just knowing that and
knowing that talent is sort of an odd
counterpoint to Batman at least as
portrayed in this movie that just makes
it better and that's pretty much where
my praise for this film starts and ends
everything else is terrible Damian is
somehow amazingly even more insufferable
in this movie then he was in son of
Batman
I'm never given a reason to like or root
for this kid yes I get he's got some
legitimate issues with Batman being as
that and Batman himself is not a
particularly good father figure but this
kid doesn't need a father figure this
kid needs military school quite
literally the very first thing we see
this kid do is steal the Batmobile and
flat-out lie to Batman and he's just so
uppity and snotty and demanding respect
but he gives none gives absolutely none
and I do understand that teenagers
particularly trouble teenagers are
actually like that but understanding
that something has a grounding in
reality the way certain people actually
are doesn't mean that it's entertaining
or that I want to watch it it's an
animation it doesn't have to be more
real and actually that's that's sort of
why I've turned around on this in terms
of even the action season the action
scenes are fine but they are
choreographed concede shot and shown
very much in the way that a live-action
action film would be done and an
animation frankly that bores me there's
nothing interesting about watching a
fight between Batman and Damian where
you shoot it like it was a fight in
something like John wick I mean John
wick was awesome and had awesome fight
scenes but you're gonna put it in
animation give me something else do
something with the fact that you aren't
tethered to the constraints of reality I
understand these are just too
but I may at least have them flip around
a little bit more something anything I
mean it's just dull as heck and I
realized during that fight when Batman
and Damian were slugging it out that I
just didn't care who won which also
brought me to the realization that
Batman is worse than this one than usual
now I've been pretty apologetic even
praising of Jason Tamara's performance
as Batman up to this point here's
something I didn't realize until we got
to this movie though he's played Batman
in all those other films he hasn't
really done Bruce Wayne before now in
this one he spends quite a by the time
as Bruce Wayne and he's just not very
good as Bruce Wayne he's not terrible
but there's almost no distinction
between him being Batman and him being
Bruce Wayne and if you saw my son of
Batman review you remember I talked
about Batman's moral compass being a bit
out of whack it is even worse here
because it goes to the fundamental
conflict of the film and screws
everything up basically the major part
of the divide between Batman and Damian
aside from the fact that they don't
completely have a lot of faith and trust
in each other is that Damian was trained
as an assassin to use lethal force
Batman doesn't use lethal force and does
not believe it's ever justified that's
really kind of the root of the division
between the two of them but when Batman
is confronted with assassin sent by the
court of owls
then instead he gets their master
knocked off and they look just slightly
less than human and not usually
monstrous they look like people but
there's something wrong with them he
starts blowing them up I mean he doesn't
know if they are undead infected humans
if they're hypnotized mutated if they're
being controlled he has no idea about
any of this just that doesn't look
totally normal
cool I can kill it now we as the
audience know enough about these things
to know that they're not really human
they're kind of on borrowed time anyway
but Batman doesn't know that it wouldn't
be such a problem if he wasn't
chastising Damian for wanting to use
lethal force and then immediately
turning around and doing this it makes
me not like Batman this thing this thing
is just a mess and I just I
aside from the villain Jeremy Sisto does
great work but other than that I just I
can't give this a pass on anything the
action as I said is decent but the
action is carries these things less and
less and less for me woody just saw me
because it's the only thing that's any
good but it's not that inventive and
it's not that fun it's just decent it's
decent and one thing that's decent is
not gonna carry a movie that completely
fails to understand these characters why
they're fun or make me care about them I
really just want to give up on the new
52 based DC animated continuity that
they've got going on I don't know if I
can cuz I love animation and I'm a
little bit of a completist so I may keep
slogging through these anyways but I
just I need something else I just need I
don't know what I need so did you see
Batman versus Robin if you did I'm sorry
and share your thoughts down in the
comments let's talk about it and as for
me I'll be back too as soon as I get my
next fix assuming it doesn't kill me